hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in Thomas aquinas's sumatelogai Prima
pars question two which has to do with
the existence of God Thomas Aquinas will
tell us that there's five main ways to
argue for or to reveal the existence of
God to the interested querying person
and the first of these is actually from
what we can translate as change or a
little bit more literally motion ex
parte motus right we'll talk about what
maltus means in just a moment because
it's important to create a dissociation
between our present day understanding of
motion and the broader sense that it has
but he also says interestingly enough
that this way is the most evident or
obvious or clear
manifesty order so that's why he starts
with the first way it's not set up like
well if you don't buy this then maybe
you'll buy this all of these are sort of
complementary ways of arguing for the
existence of something that he'll he'll
say in the end this is what everybody
calls God right and we'll get to that in
just a bit
so motion or change motives includes all
sorts of changing and it's not just like
billiard balls hitting each other and
transferring a certain amount of force
to each other or you know to use an
example that uh Thomas will bring up a
little bit later in this this thing
talking about a stick a Bakula
needing to be moved by a hand if the
hand does not move the stick the stick
won't move anything else right so it
includes that kind of motion but it also
includes Changing State you know coming
into being
being corrupted or breaking down into
things movement and in place all those
sorts of things and so he'll use another
example of fire causing wood to become
actually hot in this way causing change
causing motives in the wood so what is
change so Thomas is going to be using an
Aristotelian metaphysical framework in
which
what it is to change is to go from
potentiality potentia possibility you
could also say or power right those are
all ways of translating this a capacity
is another way going from potential to
now it's translated in different ways
and I do want to mention that the
Blackfriars translation here
not the best because it talks about
perfection
in Latin it's actually octus which we
can translate as the cognit ACT but also
as actuality right activity is kind of
connected to this as well
so going from potential to actuality and
you know many things have the potential
for many different changes our bodies
are a prime example very complicated
structure capable of being you know in
general healthy or sick right these
opposites that we can put together but
then you know healthy exists in many
different ways and you can be healthier
we'll put all that aside for the moment
hopefully you've got your head around
this notion that what's happening when
something is changing is it's moving
from a potentiality that it has to an
actuality of it a you know more of it
being what it is you could say
now how does this happen
so
Thomas points out that a thing by itself
cannot move itself from potentiality to
actuality it requires something else to
do that and we call this causation right
and it can happen in a number of
different ways the second main way of
proving God's existence is going to rely
on what we call efficient causality but
there's also for Thomas Aquinas as for
any Aristotelian material causality
final causality formal causality all of
these are connected together in
interesting ways so that's all set up
that's contained within this this
article for the argument that's going to
be made so the argument itself goes like
this
we notice that something in the world is
moved or changed
Mundo right and you know you could
translate it as just something in a very
generic sense we could say listen we see
things plural in the process of change
including ourselves right but all these
other things around us sometimes we even
make things change you know I eat the
breakfast it's down in my stomach gets
dissolved and digested and it becomes
more me right that's being transformed
in the process now Aquinas says we can
grasp this with our senses he's not
saying that we can grasp cause and
effect with our senses he's saying that
what our senses take in is the fact that
things do change
how do they change here's where we start
to move Beyond just sensibility and we
start to take on a metaphysical
Viewpoint about the world one that you
know is is fairly common sensical
um you know we could say that scientists
also believe this and so do all sorts of
other people know effect without some
sort of other thing which is a cause
which is taking the something in the
world that's moved from its potential to
actuality from its potencia to octaves
so there's something else he says
by something else right so he says that
um
to cause change is to bring into being
what was previously only able to be this
can only be done
by something that already is so there's
a priority to the causer compared to the
caused or changed or moved the effect
right
so this is something that
is is in being has actuality and it's
causing something else to have that so
let's look at the example that he uses
now fire and wood he says that fire
um is actually hot right it's it's uh it
says secret uh kalidum in Octo it is hot
in act right and then the fire is
touched to a piece of wood a lignum and
the wood is hot in potential or in
potency in potencia right it's not yet
hot and we took it in from outside from
the woodshed right so we put the wood on
the fire the fire is touching it now the
wood is able to get hot and combustion
there's a whole bunch of other stuff
that we could talk about going on there
but you don't want to get too far into
the weeds with this so it causes the
wood which is able to be hot which has
the potential for that to become
actually hot in this way it causes
change in the wood so prime example
there that I think is fairly intuitive
to wrap your head around and then we
could say all right well
what caused this something else it
didn't like make itself just be what it
is any more than this thing did it
didn't bring its own potentiality
potentiality to actuality so there has
to be another thing another cause behind
that and so on and so on and we can go
back uh very far with these sets these
matrices of causes
could we go back endlessly
to Infinity as we say
um and Thomas says Hulk outum known as
Pro quedere in infinitum right what does
that mean uh so this process cannot go
back procedure it cannot go on in
infinitum endlessly without any sort of
limit why not
so here's an interesting part of the the
argument right it's not just well you
just can't go back to Infinity
because you never get the entire process
started if you're just kicking the
metaphysical can all the way down the
road you need to have some sort of first
mover or changer which is the bringing
of of other things out of their
potentiality into actuality that's what
it does right so there has to be a
premium moves a first mover is how this
is said or else nothing happens and
here's where he brings up the example of
the stick and the hand it is only when
acted on by the first cause right that
the intermediate causes will produce any
change if the hand doesn't move the
stick the stick will not move anything
else so there has to be some first cause
of change right
we have to arrive fats or derive odd Ali
quote premam moves some sort of first
mover quote a nullo movetor which is not
moved by anything else and here we get
the famous formula this all understand
as or by however you want to translate
it God Hulk omnis intelligent damn so
one way of understanding God would be as
this first mover or changer lacking
which
no other movement or change could really
be taking place but we know that it is
taking place so therefore there must be
such a first mover and that is God